foreign
[Music]
been kind of missing him
and I know he's gone because
normally he calls up and harasses my
wife about how
remember his tomatoes are doing than
ours
and our tomatoes are doing pretty damn
good this year so
I just thought I'd come
see what it feels like
[Music]
this past winter we had a unfortunate
event occur yeah house fire we lost one
of our esteemed Elders of our community
Gary moberger
when you lose an elder in a small
community like ours you know it's the
loss has really just been calculable
he was a huge part of this community and
everybody and its lives
he had a heart of gold and I sure do
miss him
foreign
actually just live by the seat of his
pants
all I needed was a rifle and a
and a blue tarp and he was good to go
but one thing I've learned in my time on
the planet is that when tragedy strikes
everybody's got to kind of come together
prop each other up
living in poor protection could be
extremely dangerous
without the community your chances of
survival are pretty damn Slim
[Music]
there's this newer Generations coming in
here and they're willing to get their
hands dirty and that's what we need to
keep this Village going
the best way to carry on Gary's Legacy
is keep passing on his knowledge
Jared with the new folks
we're the ones that are the next
generation of people coming up I want to
do everything in my power to make sure
Port protection is thriving again thank
you
we need to rise up and rebuild
[Music]
this is the dog and pony show
who's the dog who's the pony
this is how you build things out here or
move things
one
terrible inch at a time
but look at that see it's yeah okay now
we're going to come up to make sure that
that second roller is underneath where
there yeah I've got this much room it's
coming
and away we go yeah I wasn't stopping
that
gravity always wins eventually
oh we got the the main fire pump out and
we're getting this fire boat as empty as
possible to take it into the shipyard in
the closest city which is 100 mile round
trip basically
we're bringing it up to the 21st century
I can't even express the horrible
tragedy of losing Gary in the fire
that was the last time we used the fire
boat and it had some shortcomings so we
gotta get this boat whipped back into
shape ASAP
I don't like what I'm seeing in here
I'm seeing electrolysis up the kazoo
corrosion from the aluminum
we might have deeper problems than we
thought
we're gonna have to definitely assess
exactly how much damage occurred here
laughs
might like to say I want to be here for
Life
the old fisherman we don't die we just
kind of Drift Away
[Applause]
73 gallons of number two
yeah fuel out here is not cheap
but
part of the cost of doing business
my name is Carl Hernandez and I have
lived in poor protection my entire life
I stayed in poor protection
because I don't feel like I really
belong anywhere else
my main income Source has always been
fishing
I started working on deck and helping
out when I was like seven for my dad
I want to do kind of what my parents did
they bought a piece of land built a
house
built the life you know Gill netting
trolling
their own Empire if you will
you know I got to be a part of that and
uh I feel like it's my turn now you know
I wanna I wanna build my Empire
with the person that I would like to
spend my life with
would you like some coffee and I didn't
put a slash cold water in there yes
I know you
my name is Morgan turcotte and I've
lived in poor protection for a year
I grew up in Petersburg Alaska
I did not want to live paycheck to
paycheck
I met and fell in love with Carl and
he's going to marry me he just doesn't
know it yet
and it's gonna happen I'm just waiting
for it
the whale's going crazy out there oh
speeding
a good sign
oh it's well
this Gill net fishing season means a lot
to us right now because we are building
a house and we have to make our money
and pay our bills and get things going
to build our Empire
each week we get a certain amount of
time to fish
good morning so we get 48 hours to get
our net in the water and catch as much
fish as we can get
so we need to get our ice and get
fishing
[Music]
y'all
oh but it doesn't open till noon it's 11
o'clock right now
so every week on Sunday at noon on the
dot you can start fishing we've got us a
nice open spot here there's no countdown
you know but everybody kind of pays
attention we have our GPS on or
something reliable that tells you what
time it is
one minute less than a minute
we are really fishing for anything that
will go on our net so right now it's
dogs it's humpies hopefully Sockeye and
cohos as well
right now as of 1201 we've got the next
48 hours to get as much fish as we can
get
so as next 48 hours is extremely
important we're fishing now we'll hope
we're catching
living out here it's a very small
community
everybody's like part of your family
and you know every time somebody farted
basically
[Music]
thank you
it's a really big day for me
the opening day of subsistence deer
hunting
it's huge
your odds have
begging a deer are pretty damn good
when deer season first opens the deer
aren't used to the hunters being out
there and they're not used to being shot
at so your odds are pretty good if you
see a buck you're gonna get them because
they're not spooky yet
Bella you better be on today if I need
you
it's a huge part of my diet I get plenty
of meat for the year off of deer hunting
but do you know it's game on my
intention is to fill my freezer
so I'm gonna push myself to my body's
limit
I like this spot the Deer uh
and look around
I like coming and checking out by these
rivers and streams because uh
all the animals always go to water
eventually
and there's lots of nice green grass
berries everything they like
oh
bear get on this Trail
more big
it's like he was just here when I drove
up
makes me wonder if he's watching me
Bears always make me nervous because
they're unpredictable
you never know if they're gonna have
Cubs or what you don't want to sneak up
on them
it makes me
just be a little more conscious of my
surroundings
pay attention to any movement in the
bushes
I don't like surprising bears
[Music]
guys in the world
to be able to live here
and just to see what I see every day
[Music]
like these old boats around here could
talk or they'd sure tell you a story or
two of that
be pretty interesting too
I'm trying to find some sort of
makeshift garden bed I figure if I can
find an old skiff or
bathtub or anything like that'll will do
for a garden bed
I got I just don't really see anything
that's catching my eye around here I
get in another spot that I can check out
I know of an old skiff from years ago
that used to be up in the woods there
and I'm gonna go see if I can find it
I want to grow my own vegetables cost a
lot of money to get the produce out here
you know I mean the freight alone will
kill you
what's this
it's gonna be down
there's a
flat bottom skiff it's almost considered
an artifact
I don't know how the hell I'm gonna get
it out of here I guess the first step
would be is get all this damn Moss off
of it and try to get it unburied here
and
hell it's even got a tree growing on it
you know look at that
he put all these screws in where the
rivets used to be this thing must have
leaked like a damn sieve
well Junior let's go
see if we can get this thing in the
water somehow
and thinking about maybe attempting to
yank this thing out into the
into the bay with the skip I don't know
how it'll work but if he's packing it or
dragging it
hopefully it'll just slide right across
there like boil okra
so I'm gonna hit the bowel this skip off
of some of that line and I'm gonna
proceed to try to yank this thing out of
the woods and get it as close to the
water as they can hopefully even in the
water hey I guess we're blowing towards
the beach Junior I figure that's the
easiest way and besides I like pulling
thank you
[Applause]
there she comes
[Music]
that was freaking cool
yeah
Junior
[Music]
[Applause]
she's a thinker
holy
there she goes out of sight
this little skiff sinks you know there's
a good chance that it could pull my
skiff that I'm pulling it with
underwater and get my engines swamped oh
come on I don't want that to happen
[Music]
[Applause]
ah there it comes thank God he was
headed out of Davy Jones's Locker
only thing I can do right now is go like
hell and don't slow down
because it will sink
as they keep it going we'll get her to
my Beach
success
we got her home
aha
my new garden bed
[Music]
supposedly good stuff to clean aluminum
with here in this jug it's a
basically a mild acid this will give us
a lot better
idea of how deep this corrosion is
you know we
've built our community building fire
hall just for this boat
I was only 23 years old I think
she's a in store need of a little TLC I
think the next thing we need to rinse
wherever that acid was
the day doesn't pass that I don't drop
on the knowledge that I got directly
from the old timers that used to live
here sure ways to make sure perpetation
goes on in perpetuity is to share our
knowledge with the young folks
give them a hand whenever we can
well as I'm looking at those cork line
and just checking to see if we got
Fisher in our net
Sparks bobbin right in the crook there
bobbin
got a hit we got fish
I'm getting the hell out of here
there's just too much fresh Bear poo
around
[Music]
[Laughter]
actually my favorite kind of bear is a
gummy bear
I'm not afraid of those at all and you
can tell
you the only thing all right
well now I'm off to go see if I can
round up some soil
[Applause]
well we got her all Juiced out now look
at that well it's not leaking no it's
not all the way through but man those
are some deep pits all right
the main thing is we can get to town
with it without being rescued yeah
no no rescue missions no going down with
the boat damn it
I guess it's time to make sure that we
can
have the main up in operation get that
ready before we leave yeah
oh
it's always a touchy subject when we
have to actually bring the boat into
town to get service because it leaves us
out here without the protection of the
fire boat
all right now we're just uh pulling the
hose out then we'll fire up the pump and
uh make sure that uh in our absence
whoever's here will be able to throw
some water at a fire if it occurs
[Music]
that's good Dave to tell we can make
sure that this is all fully functional
we're not going to leave the harbor
fire in the hole
[Music]
I'm barely getting any pressure down
here I got a canker you're not fired up
far enough
something's going on
[Music]
so we definitely got some issue going on
you can see the uh the water hammer and
the interruption and the uh blow there
it's never done that before
apparently
we're gonna have to have some work done
on the uh on the water pump as well
let's kill her Sam
well at least we we have water coming
out of the hoses and it's a hell of a
lot more than a garden hose yeah
start packing up the rig for the run
tomorrow eh well hopefully the wind dies
down we have sunshine and now it's windy
open in here it's just a good place to
stop and take a peek
hopefully there's some action in here
whoa
dude
and he probably just tucked in right up
there
[Music]
quietly
in there
oh
[Music]
damn it
and that was perfect size but it was a
dough I can't shoot it
damn it
maybe I'll go in there and take it and
peek and see if she has a little
boyfriend in there
in the beginning of deer season you can
only Harvest a buck which is a male deer
but I'm gonna follow her into the woods
because if she's got her boyfriend with
her or daddy that's what I'm looking for
there she is
[Music]
underway
I gotta wave it wave at the wife
[Music]
oh every time I leave the harbor
we go through that little ritual
gotta say goodbye
you know he never might not come back
could happen
come on fishy fishy come on
come on come on
now we need some excitement
girl
ran it
well
she didn't have her honey with her
stayed right there
that's why today is so good they're not
free
now I'm gonna get back on my scooter or
not
get on down the road find me the one
with antlers
come on money
money
there's a fish yeah
first fish of the set Sockeye
it's a good sign yeah
let me help people there
is over here yeah
I don't really have a lot of experience
fishing especially commercial fishing I
mean I put a pole in the water before
and tried to catch fish but this is
completely different
I've had maybe a summer and a half under
my belt of Gill netting there's
something
hell yeah
Carl has been fishing from the time he's
been a Peewee try not to break it he
does know a lot and he is teaching me a
lot
not seeing as many fish as I'd like to
see a couple of sockeye a couple of dogs
couple of humpies and come here for no
stinking humpies
[Music]
cut ourselves a few jellyfish wow
there's a nice one look at that oh
sorry
oh that one my eye
that's what I get for trying to get out
of the net yep oh God that's gonna suck
here in about
five four three two one oh I hope it was
just water
I hope it was just water
well that was depressing
ow
God my eye hurts yeah
oh I hate it oh I hate it are you okay
[Music]
oh
ah
ah you horn
ah jellyfish in my eyeball
nice lovely burning jellyfish right in
the corner of my eye
it's great that's why you should always
wear sunglasses when you're doing this
all right let's go back up top I think
and I got some a little bit on my face
it doesn't react too bad and it tends to
react mostly with moisture so Nationals
mouth eyeballs it's uh reacts pretty bad
oh
I'm gonna try scraping along the beach
here as the tide goes out see if any
fish built up in there
[Music]
oh
how you doing kids
[Music]
me and Dave squibber heading into
Petersburg
we've got a bunch of much needed
maintenance to doing the fire boat
it's a parody we get that boat dropped
off in Petersburg so that the experts
can fix it and we can get it back home
as soon as possible
I have the capacity to fight some fire
in about a half a mile up here I'm gonna
pull over and you can come alongside and
we can we're gonna have a little snack
a little bite to eat Roger that I'm
feeling a little peckish myself I'll uh
I'll follow you into a Cove
all right well I can't think of a better
picnic spot
would you like some Tomatoes Dave oh
yeah
sometimes I eat them sometimes I don't
damn not thanks sir absolutely
made your way on up there the up the
hill
yeah I I
went back for the first time since the
fire so
it was time
you know the
I still have them here mustard the
gumption to go up on site yet made the
boardwalk a couple times but uh I'm just
kidding couldn't wait get there yet
[Music]
I can say is uh
at least yeah
[Music]
accepted the marrow of life with a smile
to the very end there I mean oh I'm
assuming yeah didn't spend the last
couple years in uh
go to the old folks home so what the
hell
we are in the old folks and we're in the
best place old folks should be as long
as
we can keep the firewood blazing yeah
food on the table
gonna miss that salty old sourdough damn
it
thinking it's probably time to fire it
up
[Music]
this is your fun
it's my happy place is where I exist
in the kelp
hey for a quick one that wasn't bad
couples better than none at this point
this wasn't that bad you'd be an
optimistic right where'd you get that
from
this is a big spruce tree that's blowed
over the only soil around here is
attached into the roots that's what I
get for my garden
and to be careful here and watch these
rocks behind me here too because
One of Them Things Fall that's gonna
ruin your day
foreign
City of Petersburg
time to get this boat up to the shipyard
yeah she's right up here
next time we see this boat she'll be as
new and improved as the fire boat has
been in a long long long time
[Music]
I'm gonna hook around this piling
figure what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
use a block and tow line
I'll tighten these lines up back down
here
and then I'll
hook onto it with my skiff and give it a
big yank and see what happens
hopefully I don't
Yang the damn piling out from underneath
my hot tub deck that would really suck
there's all kinds of rocks in the way
that could get hung up behind anything
let's go Junior so we're just gonna
cross our fingers and pull like hell
damn it I might be stuck
try this again
[Music]
holy
I hope we did her Junior I think it's up
the hill
[Music]
whoa
didn't tell us it was a bus or a doe but
it was a deer
[Music]
oh he's still there
watching for me
she went in little head
gotta go in and look around
[Music]
they're in here there's Buck Right There
let's see all their little tracks that
are in here
just gonna look for any kind of movement
or anything
[Music]
see if I can knock these seats out of
here
I got a big hammer
[Music]
hopefully knock them loose
that is one
[Music]
Little Tweety Bird
what's up
[Music]
there we go won't be long we'll be
planting seeds
just not in the cards for me today
some days you're lucky some days you're
not
but I'm not giving up
because if you keep trying you'll get
that pat hand
foreign
there she blows
at the time the mostly on down to the
Skip and see uh the improvements eh yeah
oh look at that nice pretty bottom paint
yeah
get that Bell on yeah
push up to her I'll just give it a quick
hop
oh look at how sweet That's lit up
you can hear them
hell you can even sit on on the transom
back here this is insane I am digging
I'm digging hard
they even put some silicone in a pitting
on the inside and they put a patch on
the outside
this is the cat's meow certainly how
right you are my Bright Little Star
I'll pull it around to the skiff float
and we'll uh start working on getting
the water cannon back in place
[Music]
all right
fish or bust
oh there's humpies Jumping All in here
oh that's good to see come on
come on one good set see if we can scare
some fish into the net real quick
it's yesterday the first couple sets
were not good actually by any stretch
but day two we got a way better idea
where to be when
oh look at that
oh man looking a hell of a lot better
there's a nice school oh damn it they're
all going through oh thank you Jesus I
can see why you love and hate your job
right there's ups and there's Downs it's
great when you're catching fish when
you're not you just want to hang
yourself it's like I'm done I just want
to sink the boat walk away never come
back
[Music]
oh we got a big one
the is that
that better not be what I think it is
right there
is it
is that a sea lion
no it's just a seal
don't you eat my fish
got something I can throw at them
foreign
I saw him tugging on a fish down there
eating the belly out of it right now
let's try and scare him off
[Music]
bye bye okay we might have to start
picking our way out of this a little bit
Hello Maybe
make some money
damn seal
that giant hole on the side of it
that's what the seal does so
it's not that bad he was trying for it
at least it was a humpy
he's a fish
oh there's a lot of sock out here this
is good
sockeyes are
the highest dollar fish we catch
this is kind of what I was hoping for
but definitely worked out better than
expected
for more than breaking even definitely
more than breaking even
we did get a little bit ahead not enough
where we need to be but it is a start
and hopefully this can keep up through
the rest of our Gill net season
this has been
successful sometimes you make the Right
Moves
[Music]
I know I got some carrots and turnips I
want to stick in the ground and
then you get the damn things open
like that
there we go I consider myself kind of a
soft bee a Sentimental guy
I mean just having that skiff there it
takes me back to that time when things
are a lot easier I had a skiff exactly
like it when I was a kid man
I had to work my butt off in the hay
fields and I pulled tansy too for the
farmers and worked all summer to save
enough money to get that skip
it was a
my price possession for a long time
and a lot of good Adventures on that
thing going up and down the old Scatter
Creek trapping duck hunting and fishing
all my other friends were getting in
trouble I was out there having fun yeah
boy those were those were some good
times back then not a worry in the world
yes that's that
I'm super stoked that the skiff is up
here and done and my Garden's planted uh
water relief and best thing of all is
I'm gonna have uh carrots and turnips in
my bear stew now hopefully the damn
crows don't eat it all
[Music]
right here we go
nice
let's go spray some water
see what she's got
[Music]
what we're witnessing now is basically a
Changing of the Guard
the old-timers are slowly passing away
but we do have an influx some new blood
young folks that are attracted to this
part of the world
and they're a pretty Hardy lot
that's hopefully going to help
Revitalize the community of Port
protection
we've got our work cut out for us
first bag's all humpies
it's a different lifestyle growing up
for sure you know you don't get your
Summers out of school playing and having
a good time it's uh to work
but as a young kid seeing that it's kind
of cool
222.
and uh this is where I want to be
building up our Empire
[Music]
I came out here for a simpler lifestyle
and just to get all the stress out of my
life I've done that but it's not simpler
by no means it's a lot of work
starting to get up there in age but I
prefer to live the way I I do live
I gotta work my ass off to get something
I need then so be it well he loves
retrieving oh you gotta have a strong
back and a weak mind to live out here
junior good boy
every single one of us is going to live
on with Gary's spirit in our hearts
the community is going to have to band
together
take a deep breath there's another day
coming
[Music]
take hold as a peach damn that's nice
man yeah well inevitably we're gonna
have to pull this puppy back out of the
barn and go fight
well we'll be ready for it
[Music]
there's no no way that I would want to
change my life
The Call of the Wild drew me out and I
could never leave
[Music]
this is a gem in its own way it's a
beautiful place
[Music]
poor protection is kind of been a
crossroad There She Goes
last decade we've really lost a lot of
the sourdoughs the pillars of our
community
spot in any founder
a handful of young folks out here now
that are pretty Hardy and they have the
right stuff in a critical time who need
I feel like I caught a fish man I feel
like a stud dude hell yeah I feel a
certain responsibility to keep it alive
like to really push stops
real important for people like me to
pass along as much as I can
[Music]
that's the sea monster
these young people don't learn how to
survive it's a very fabric because the
community is going to fail yeah I see a
bear either
seen a lot of people that had left their
tails between their legs had big goals
to not be one of those successful day if
you ask me
this is where I want to be this is my
end game it may be hard work but we're
ready for it
here called if you were chosen
[Music]